Though it was something of a box office disappointment
when it first hit theaters in 1997, Luc Besson's
whacked-out sci-fi epic The FIfth Element
has since become a cult classic thanks to
gonzo visuals and quirky performances from
stars Bruce Willis, Milla Jovovich, and Chris
Tucker.
But despite the film's popularity, there has
never been a follow-up.
Here's a look at some of the reasons why The
Fifth Element never got a sequel.
It wasn't a huge hit
The Fifth Element didn't fare particularly
well during its theatrical release in the
United States, which was a problem because
at the time, the movie's $90 million-plus
price tag made it the most expensive film
ever produced outside of Hollywood.
While the film would go on to break some international
box office records by pulling in $263 million
worldwide, it scored just $63 million of that
take from U.S. theaters - which is probably
a big reason an equally expensive sequel wasn't
quick to get the green light.
The story was complete
Though Besson originally envisioned The Fifth
Element as part of a trilogy, the story of
main characters Korben and Leeloo actually
feels pretty complete at the end of the film.
He's rediscovered his vigor for life, she's
found a reason to want to save the Earth,
the pair have found love together, and in
the process, they've literally brought peace
to the galaxy.
Sure, Besson could probably find a clever
way to shake these two out of their well-earned
happiness.
At this point, though, it might feel more
like a desperate cash grab, especially considering
Willis is now in his mid-60's.
Much as fans would like to see more, nobody
wants to see The Fifth Element's legacy tarnished
by an unnecessary second act.
"It's a very nice hat."
"You liked it?!"
Offscreen drama
One of the biggest complicating factors when
it comes to a sequel is the offscreen drama
between Besson and Jovovich.
During filming of The Fifth Element, the two
became romantically involved and got married
not long after the film's premiere.
It didn't last, though, as their relationship
fell apart on the set of their 1999 collaboration
The Messenger: The Story of Joan of Arc.
The film flopped, and the couple divorced
the same year.
Still, anything is possible — according
to Jovovich, their relationship worked a lot
better on set than off set.
She told the Scottish Daily Record,
"If we could make movies 365 days a year,
we would still be together.
Luc and I have this unique creative connection.
We did get married.
But we're not together anymore in that sort
of particular context.
We're best friends, apart from being together
or not.
He loves me, I love him."
Besson's enigmatic career
When it comes to sequels, you should always
strike while the iron is hot.
But after the mess that was The Messenger:
The Story of Joan of Arc and the dissolution
of his marriage to Jovovich, Besson went the
other direction, stepping away from directing
entirely for six years to focus on writing
instead.
That break may have squandered any momentum
for a Fifth Element sequel, but that's par
for the course for Besson, who doesn't seem
to be interested in revisiting his past as
a director.
Other than a couple of animated films, Besson
has never directed a sequel, even passing
the reins of the proposed follow-up to his
2014 hit Lucy.
It seems it would have to take something pretty
special to convince him to return to the world
of The Fifth Element.
Special effect frustrations
When The Fifth Element arrived in theaters,
it was regarded as bona fide special effects
bonanza.
But according to Besson, the special effects
in The Fifth Element were frustrating to work
with, because the technology didn't exist
yet to truly fulfil his vision.
Perhaps if the effects had existed at the
time, Besson would have moved forward with
the rest of the trilogy, but now that the
technology does finally exist, he seems to
have moved on to other projects.
Speaking of which...
A spiritual sequel
Though Besson has suggested in interviews
that he might be open to filming other stories
set in the same universe as The Fifth Element,
for the last decade most of his energy seems
to have been turned towards his big screen
adaptation of the long running French comic
book series Valerian and the City of a Thousand
Planets.
Filled with mind-blowing imagery only made
possible by advances in effects over the past
20 years, Valerian and the City of a Thousand
Planets unfortunately failed to launch at
the box office, taking in just $225 million
worldwide against a huge $177 million budget.
Since the film underperformed, the future
of the franchise is up in the air, but considering
Besson was reportedly planning to break his
own rule against sequels by turning Valerian
into a trilogy, it seems as though his heart
just isn't in The Fifth Element any more.
Never say never
Though there's an argument to be made that
it's often better to leave your fanbase wanting
more, Besson still shows a lot of affection
for the world of The Fifth Element, and that
would seem to leave the door open—if only
slightly—for a sequel.
Even if Korben and Leeloo aren't at the center
of the story, we'd still love to see where
Besson might take things next—just as long
as it isn't a Ruby Rhod origin story.
All due respect to Besson and Chris Tucker,
but some characters are just more fun in small
doses.
"All night looong!
All night.
Ooooh!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!